- time confence consensus first-team
all-american two-time Big Ten Player of
the Year at the Ohio State University
before 14 seasons in the Association
after being the first overall pick of
the 92 draft he works for Fox Sports as
a college basketball NBA studio analyst
but in this role from Westwood One
Sports after calling the LOS
angeles-based Regional semifinal games
last night at Staples Jim Jackson good
to see okay oh wait
i sat in the right location I did what I
was saying I was sat in the right
location during the big moments against
Houston I think that year the set up of
the final shot was because I got off of
the unlucky spot you know is that right
yeah you believe that oh yeah okay oh
yeah
you weren't superstitious as a bulwark
you know I was actually I still am
because I eat a pretzel before a game Oh
which is crazy my later in my career
first first I started out with M&Ms and
then I went to a pretzel and even when I
do my games now when I call a game I get
a pretzel before the game I don't know
why
no realm of reason right but I just do
it what prompted the switch from Eminem
depends no I was watching I don't know
maybe I went from sweets to just more
carbs I don't like well look by the way
it doesn't look like you're it's it's
hanging on right now I can't play any
defense but I'll [ __ ] you God so what
did you take out of last night's games
what sticks you know but you know you
know what's funny
rich is that over the last probably five
to eight years
you saw this change in college
basketball I think with mid-majors being
more competitive it was eventually gonna
happen when a 16 B to 1 you know or it
was a 12c 13c make it to the Final Four
and win a championship just because the
dynamics have changed so much because
the one-and-done the players the top
players are gone the secondary players
are now becoming our star players but
these smaller schools end up having
juniors and seniors like we see with
Loyola who are gritty has something to
prove and they're just as good so now
the competitive balance is
and it's not that big gap like we saw
before like North Carolina plan a Butler
back in early 90s there's no way it was
going to happen but now you know I see
it so I'm not surprised so the question
is is when will that be taken into
account when they're seating or even
merely selecting teams I mean it doesn't
seem like we're seeing any shift yeah
we're still seeing you know 12 13 lost
programs from big conferences in quotes
or whatever getting the ten seed nine
seed when there are smaller conference
teams that don't have a shot because
they didn't win their turn but what's
the weight system that's the question
because I don't think any system is
gonna be perfect because whoever we
select a lot of times is always gonna be
something there you take Louella
you know they won the mid in VC 29 wins
but he hadn't still they they went on
the road and beat Miami okay but yet and
still when they you weigh their schedule
their non-conference who they played who
they beat compared to a Duke or North
Carolina that if that's the scale we're
gonna weigh it on the quad one wins
versus a quad before losses things like
that but Porter motors are probably
can't get easy and that's the thing they
don't want to play them now I can hear
it to you that they don't want to play
before you probably could but it's a lot
tougher so I don't I don't know how we
balance that out with the smaller
schools to be able to be viewed upon
like a North Carolina in regards to
scheduling putting them and having them
have a higher see once the NC double-a
comes around so it's interesting that
out of last night I gave you the whole
sort of large scope of what you could
take out of last night that the highest
seed team that actually destroyed its
opponent is not the first one out of
your mouth Jim I'm wondering if there's
something there's something to that well
you know actually actually I had
Michigan in the Final Four Martin
Brackett early because I was your thing
I've learned being from Ohio and losing
to Michigan in the Elite Eight and I'll
tell you what anytime this game comes
around yes okay every year and it comes
on classic sports so they play our
league Elite Eight game against Michigan
I'm hoping for a different result but it
doesn't change
hey I'm eventually I'm hoping the
timeout doesn't get called again
Carolina also it's not granted every
single time no but what I've learned by
covering Michigan is the genius behind
John Beilein okay and I really saw it
back in 2014 when it plays Syracuse and
he kind of dismantled that 2-3 zone okay
in just his thought process and the way
he's accepted us when I was with the Big
Ten Network he opened his doors show us
to be able to have you know full
coverage of the team and kind of insight
into what he was thinking so as I watch
him coach and I'm just sitting there
watching his Michigan team you got four
players basically I was at a Xavier
Simpson that can shoot it they shared a
basketball their unselfish they play
together high intelligence so I'm
looking at the game and I'm watching
Mitch I said this Michigan team based on
where they're seated can get to a final
four and you can play some serious
defense he's from while you know that
there's those state lines get crossed
quite a bit now I was right know that so
but what is beelines genius then take me
inside what you see and what is being
done seemingly year after year molding a
clay into a champion yeah and run
potential you know he did it at West
Virginia but probably didn't have the
same caliber of players you know when he
had you know tre young and Glen Roberts
in the third he had you know Tim
Hardaway jr. that's when you saw
everything kind of come together because
these were pros he had finally to run
his system and those that system and
those pros took him to the championship
game the ability for him to understand
the talents the strengths of his players
and put them in those situations he's
not gonna have a prototypical center
which the game doesn't have but at movig
know what he's able to do on the court
to stretch the floor to open up the
passing lanes and driving lanes
he puts guys in position as spacing is
great but he puts a premium on thinking
the game I'm a pass on time on target am
I gonna turn the ball over and we're not
gonna beat ourselves and honestly this
year there's probably one of the best
defensive teams that nobody's really
talking about that's what allowed me win
the first two games when they weren't
shooting well Jim Jackson Westwood one
Fox Sports here on the Rich Eisen show
before we turn to tonight what do you
make out of Kentucky not shaking hands
I don't like it I mean because if it
when you win you're celebrating okay and
you shake hands and you do everything
you want to do the losing team comes to
you when you lose you you lose with
dignity okay let me tell you something
67 teams are gonna lose there's only one
it's gonna walk away and be happy
coach John Calipari should have got
those guys and bring him back out the
locker room and went out there and shook
their hands because we're all we all
hate to lose you guys wanted to lose at
Michigan after we beat them twice but
you know what I had respect for that
other locker room and I shook their hand
and our coach wasn't gonna allow us not
to do it anyway so I think it is a sign
of disrespect because when you're
winning and you're on top everything is
great but when you lose lose with some
dignity how come that doesn't happen in
the pros it's never been any enemy I
know individually you may go up to a
friend to somebody you know and tell
them now you see it a lot more I think
in today's game with a lot of guys after
the game having conversations and
talking right know before when I came in
you know we might point a finger be like
I a good game and walk off now a lot of
guys really interact after again because
they grew up playing AAU together you
know these all-star games together so
they have more of a personal thing
relationship over the years so now it's
no big thing for them to have a
conversation to shake hands to do things
after a game but it is definitely an
unwritten rule that you don't believe
should be violated in common no at all
after the game win lose a draw you go
shake the opposing team's hand and you
walk off the court all right so Jim
Jackson Westwood 1 you're gonna be
calling me regionalism here between
Florida State and Michigan let's talk
about tonight let's talk about tonight
you've got Texas Tech xoring Keys West
Virginia in Clemson against Purdue Duke
Villanova in Kansas respectively which
lower seed do you think can continue
this lower seed uprising that we've seen
well Syracuse just from the fact that
it's funny because I'm watching the game
when they play against Michigan State
hidden his own defense and I'm just like
I mean they're long the athletic they
don't look like it it really can't score
that's why they want to hold you to like
52 points
but it's something about that zone
because guys are not accustomed to
playing against enriched I mean all year
you're planning his man-to-man
somebody is sprinkle in a 2-3 zone and
but it's not for the whole game you play
good says it's all in the whole game and
the way you gotta beat it is you I think
you got to isolate and make it more
two-on-one situations whether it's in
the corner up top but Syracuse is one of
those seams a few years ago they came in
and everybody was saying the same thing
they shouldn't be in a tournament and
they I know and then they went on a run
but that's right Duke has played
Syracuse before yeah runs the 2-3 itself
this year but he did its success he did
it because he wanted to play Marvin
Bagley and Wendell Carter together
defensively if he doesn't play zone
they're gonna get either to eat enough
man-to-man so Mike is smart forget it
plays all we can rebound out of his own
so it's gonna be interesting to team but
Duke shoots the ball love them Syracuse
doesn't so advantage to do so you think
if tonight's gonna be more chalky than
yeah I think it is I think it is if you
look at you know Villanova so I picked
two also to win it all just because one
I love Jay Wright but then I got five
guys that can shoot it on the court
their centers are shooting three-point
shots they they don't turn the ball over
I mean they're it's fabulous to watch
how they play unselfishly
I mean West Virginia can they transfer
that press over can they score enough
points can they not go through those
scoring laws you know all it takes is
three to four minutes in a one game
scenario I could that could be your
season so I think it's gonna be more
interest in interesting games I think
tonight than it was yesterday
okay well I mean you know we did see
some some close ones there was one night
right in front of you though I mean that
they I could not believe that they were
just throwing that ball in the oh she
was due last night it was different or
do they had to that Michigan had two
poor games and Florida State I mean they
also had a round of 32 moment where it
looked they were dead I know and so
they're the Seminoles are are a good
team and they are really well coached
you know what is funny thing about it
they're not they don't impress you with
that they don't have that one player
that you just like okay
while he's MBA he's but what does
Michigan know I mean well that's it when
Mo Vaughn ER is playing yes I mean he's
it he's a NBA player but he could do it
I mean he can run the floor and he can
shoot you threes he could even he looks
the part - okay but here's the thing we
were interviewing um coach Hamilton he
said this says I thought this was very
genes he said listen we're not the
blueblood program okay the dukes of
North Carolina's Syracuse and ACC
they're seven is gonna be better than
our seven but our eleven is better than
their eleven and what he's meet what he
means is we're gonna go deep in our
bench and play eleven guys and try to
wear teams down so if we're there at the
end of the game now you're you're
mentally fatigued and we have the event
so he understands who they are as a team
they're not gonna get the five star
player they're not gonna get the one and
done but he's built the program like you
did at Miami and some other places that
are built on quantity with a little bit
of quality in there in order to be
successful all right so I want to take a
break come back talk NBA we don't bet we
can okay cuz we're getting down to the
nitty-gritty right here and I just last
night Brockman I had a thought because I
saw a great moment last night in the
Eastern Conference made me want to back
my play on the Sixers a little bit more
I think I know where you're going and
it's it might be a hot take involving
LeBron James but since you work it you
know Fox you're used to that
huh takes yeah hey guys when we come
back here on the rich a friendship
Jim Jackson here from Fox Sports and
Westwood one perfect timing
news is breaking Chris Brockman give him
the news right here that's just broken
in the Association yeah the Celtics have
announced that Kyrie Irving who is
celebrating a birthday today
26 well undergo a minimally evasive
procedure on his left knee no timetable
in return
Adrian wood Janowski added that the
timetable will come after the surgery
tomorrow source says expectation that
will help alleviate the soreness that
he's been dealing with this year so my
take on that is knee surgery is
minimally invasive as long as it's not
your knee they got that right exactly
they can put all the lighten what you
want but anytime you got a cut on
something you just don't know what's
gonna happen but in today's world with
technology and the way they do surgeries
he should be fine but it's just tough
for a Kyrie remember he was talking
about having surgery before the tray
that's right didn't use that as a threat
yes they said well if something happens
out there's have surgery and sit out so
how much was it bothering him during the
course of the years the question you
know cuz he was playing phenomenal that
was unbelievable man unbelievable
so that would that would tilt a little
bit of the balance one would think and
then the way that the Cavs have been
playing recently I didn't think Boston
was ready quite yet to overthrow
Cleveland even with all those struggles
that Cleveland going no because you got
to understand something again it's a
seven game series series it's not three
or five the Boston team the guys that
you're gonna lean on heavily were young
with jaylen brown and Tatum they were
young tilda to be able to come into this
league and to win in the Eastern
Conference Finals to get to the finals
to be to LeBron James the Kevin Love
team that's tough I don't care how good
Kyrie is and Horford and Brad Stevens is
still young from that perspective so
it's almost like you know when Detroit
had to get through Boston when Chicago
had to get through Detroit it was a
process it took a minute a maturity of
kind of getting your head beat in a
little bit right and you finally got
over the top so I didn't think I thought
it'd be an intriguing story but I didn't
think Boston could really beat Cleveland
in a seven-game scenario so then who can
be Cleveland any seven-game scenario
Wednesday
I've got an idea here should I grab the
hot take plank I think you should
because this is about to be I mean it's
not scorching but it's pretty it's
pretty pretty hot okay here on this show
there's a hot take I grabbed this piece
of wood
what was it Kennesaw State our Super
Bowl shows back in in Arizona so I
clutch the plank when I'm going hot
taking okay but I called the Sixers as a
playoff team back in October I just I
saw em bead looking healthy and I just
saw what Simmons was supposed to be and
was looking like November I thought they
were making the playoffs it looks like
they might take on Cleveland
and as I clutch this hot take plank and
just seeing em beat last night taking no
look essential three-point shot last
night I thought this is going to be the
April 4mb to just capture the fancy of
this nation and the Philadelphia
sensation of the Superbowl they're still
feeling it in that town they can want I
think they're gonna want and done the
Cleveland Cavaliers one and done what
one and done the Cleveland Cavaliers
like the would seven-game series shoot
them out yes seriously
so because Maddox making the three kills
Michigan one last night that gives you
all this is just remember it's a
confidence right now to Joe actually
think no I'm an observer of the game of
what gave the association so what gives
you what gives you that kind of
confidence based on the season in the
games that Philly played against
Cleveland with Isiah and post right that
they can beat this clip this Cavs team
is seven and I'm and I like the Philly
team it's why I'm clutching a piece of
wood at least I give you it at least I'm
not just masking it and just saying that
I've truly truly truly believe it but I
feel it okay I have a feeling the
sensation well you got watch what you
eat in the morning sometimes no but I
like the Philly team but they're not
ready come on too many holes so you say
LeBron once East yeah you see the
Toronto game the other day did you okay
so he's just he's as great as he's ever
been I mean it makes funny stuff he's
rich
been around you've covered it a long
time we're about the same age 47 48 yes
sir we've seen and I've played against
some of the best I've done it in year 15
to do what he's doing not a game is
different the rules are different
granite that's the case but to not have
a major injury to miss games basically
to have rest to drop a triple-double at
you know 16 in this 15th year to have 37
points 17 assists and no turnovers I'm
sorry I'm their only reason why I'm
laughing is cuz I'm the TV side they
split screen doesn't yes the topic are
at the bottom just because they think
we're having an argument just because
you know it's funny to with that think
about that think about that headlight
it's not with a cab Ron is playing with
they got a chance to win it thanks for
coming come on man it anytime the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience